care the sponsors of this next segment
are back to remind our seniors in the
community how to make and handle their
doctor's appointments take a look Dr
Wakefield long time no see how are you
I'm good Rocky how are you doing well
how is our senior focused Care at Center
well going it's going well definitely
we're meeting a meet here in the valley
absolutely and meeting a need meaning
reminding seniors to plan their doctor's
visit so let's just get into that first
you know why should a senior plan a
doctor's visit well we know that most
people only see their doctor maybe a
couple times a year unless they're
treating some specific you know
condition that a patient may have so
it's important to get the most out of
the visit because we know you know we
know at Center well how important it is
that the more that you are prepared the
more information you can give your
physician the better they're able to
treat you absolutely now how should
seniors prepare for a doctor's visit at
Central well really take an inventory of
you know how have you been feeling are
you exercising enough are you eating a
diet that you feel is good for you are
you getting the sleep that you need are
you having any concerns about depression
anything like that because these are
things that really impact your health so
it's important like I said to kind of
reflect on everything that's been going
on just to make sure you can bring it up
because it may be you know nothing
serious but it's something you should
definitely discuss with your provider to
find out if it is anything more serious
than you're thinking about
um now what about tips to prepare for
the actual appointment itself it's just
there be anything they bring in it's
really important to make a list right
and you know we like to be able to make
sure you know that people don't forget
what they really wanted to talk to us
about the other thing is and I know I'm
guilty as a guilty of it as a doctor we
talk fast we often use terms they may
not be easy to understand so it's okay
to tell your doctor hey slow down can
you explain this to me in a manner that
you know I can understand better because
you really have a right to understand
your health care I know at Center well
we're lucky we have a good amount of
time to spend time with our patients so
we don't you know they don't feel rushed
and they really can go over everything
they want to they may also find that
it's it's good to bring either a family
member or a friend to you know keep
track of everything that needs to be
done or you know remind them if there's
anything they didn't bring up and then
after the appointment is there anything
that she they should be prepared for
then absolutely because we know that you
know there may be something they forgot
they may have a you know a concern or an
issue with a medication so it's really
important to have a consistent you know
dialogue with your health care provider
so that they can better know you and
they can assess and continue to follow
you if anything should arise so yeah
like at Center well we feel that's
really integral to really maintaining
the health of our you know of our
patients is that constant interaction so
that we get to know you better
that is great and now how can our
seniors here in the community receive
this premium service and and experience
it's easy to become a center well
patient I would recommend you go to
centerwell lasvegas.com you can see all
of our locations on the map we're really
everywhere in the Valley now and you can
even come on come on into one of our
centers get a private tour and really
see all the amenities that we have in
the clinic and how they're suited to
really treat the needs of our seniors
thank you Center well senior primary
care for sponsoring that segment they
have 11 locations across the Las Vegas
Valley for more information all you got
to do is head to centerwell lasvegas.com
we'll be right back